Сонце та вітер - невичерпні та екологічно чисті джерела енергії.
Однак покладатися лише на них не може жодна країна світу.
Упродовж десятиліть важливу роль відіграє атомна енергетика.
Останніми роками в усьому світі будуються нові АЕС.
Для виготовлення паливних збірок для реакторів
потрібна викопна сировина - уран.
Світовий попит на нього зростає.
Де видобувається уран?
Перше місце з видобутку урану займає Казахстан.
Там видобувають понад 21 тисячу тонн на рік.
За ним слідують Канада, Намібія та Австралія.
На шостому місці - Росія.
Наразі можна говорити про те, що Казахстан перебуває у сфері впливу Росії,
і це має велике значення для Європи.
2022 року близько сорока чотирьох відсотків урану надійшло з Росії та Казахстану.
Однак справа не лише у родовищах, а й у технологіях.
Видобутий з землі уран проходить довгий шлях на різних підприємствах,
перш ніж перетворитися на паливо.
З уранової руди відділяється пуста порода,
утворена речовина проходить конверсію і збагачення,
і лише потім у вигляді "таблеток" або "капсул" вкладається у так звані
ТВЕЛи - тепловидільні елементи.
Збагачення урану - найскладніший процес.
Ним займаються лише кілька компаній у світі,
адже це прямий шлях до виробництва ядерної зброї.
Найбільшим виробником збагаченого урану у світі нині є Росія.
На її частку припадає 40% світового ринку.
Далі - Франція та Китай. Конкуренція в цій галузі поки що невелика.
Потрібно дивитися на це як на ринок.
Якщо ми купуємо уран у Канади,
а не у Росії та Казахстану, то хтось інший купить його у Росії чи Казахстану.
Якщо США не купуватимуть у них уран, пропозиція на ринку залишиться незмінною.
А звідки походить паливо на українських АЕС?
В "Енергоатомі" запевняють, що в основі палива для
атомних електростанцій України - лише український і канадський уран,
а збагачення урану відбувається саме в Канаді.
Ба більше, як запевняють в українській компанії,
в ядерній енергетиці Україна цілком незалежна від Росії.
Це історичні кадри з Рівненської АЕС.
У реактор ВВЕР-440 радянського дизайну завантажується
паливо американо-японської компанії Westinghouse.
У вересні 2023 року Україна стала першою державою у світі,
де така операція стала можливою.
на нашу вимогу, прохання розробив проєкт
цього палива для маленьких реакторів за півтора року.
Це були рекордні терміни.
В Європі таких 16 реакторів.
І зараз я знаю, що вже підписуються контракти
Westinghouse з іншими країнами європейськими на
перехід від російського палива на паливо Westinghouse.
Тобто ми поклали край монополії Росії
на виготовлення ядерного палива.
Паливо для реакторів типу ВВЕР
суттєво відрізняється за геометрією від
палива для західних аналогів реакторів типу ВВЕР.
Для того, щоб виготовити паливо та отримати
відповідну ліцензію на його використання,
знадобилося дуже багато часу.
Це навіть не роки, а майже два десятки років.
Історично на українських АЕС використовувалося
радянське, а потім російське паливо.
Але з 2005 року Україна ухвалила програму
диверсифікації - тобто почала шукати інших постачальників.
Після повномасштабного вторгнення "Енергоатом"
повністю відмовився від палива з Росії.
Тобто у нас є запас російського палива ще,
і російське паливо те, яке ми маємо на наших складах,
ми будемо використовувати.
Але всі нові партії палива, вони будуть заходити не тільки з Westinghouse.
За запасами урану Україна входить
у першу десятку країн світу.
Підприємство "Схід-ГЗК" на Кіровоградщині
видобуває уранову руду і проводить її хімічну обробку.
Це найперші етапи ядерного циклу.
Утім українська сировина вважається бідною
на корисний продукт. Видобувати її дорого.
Тож "Схід-ГЗК" перебуває у постійних боргах і кризі.
Здебільшого Україна покладається на іноземний уран
і його перетворення на паливо за кордоном.
Теоретично в Україні можна було б реалізувати
й більш технологічно складні етапи ядерного
паливного циклу - усе крім збагачення урану.
Утім експерти сумніваються в доцільності такого кроку,
надто під час війни.
Це реально складні процеси і технологічно, і науково.
Саме тому зараз використовуємо інше паливо.
До того ж, виробництво, скажімо так, обмежено.
Повний цикл виробництва економічно доцільний,
коли мова йде про декілька десятків реакторів.
В Україні це 15 реакторів, якщо враховувати ті,
що зараз є окуповані. Нема економічної доцільності в цій процедурі.
Тим не менш в "Енергоатомі" до кінця 2025 року
планують відкрити власну лінію збирання
палива за технологією Westinghouse.
Одне - фінансово-економічно складова,
інше - стратегічна складова.
Тобто якщо ми говоримо про стратегію,
то Україні потрібно мати конверсію,
Україні мати потрібно замкнутий ядерний цикл.
Тому що у нас велика атомна індустрія
тут в Україні і потрібно її розвивати.
Експерт з питань енергетики Михайло Гончар нагадує:
схожі дискусії точилися напередодні російської агресії
в 2014 році. Тоді Westinghouse планувала
створити в Україні підприємство
з виробництва тепловиділяючих збірок.
І не лише для потреб українських АЕС.
Для того, щоб підприємство гарантовано
було комерційно привабливим, потрібно, щоб воно,
по суті, теж забезпечувало паливом реактори
радянського дизайну в країнах центральної Європи:
Чехія, Словаччина, Угорщина, Болгарія.
Ну, а потім, власне, російське вторгнення змінило
багато планів.  Недаремно можна зробити висновок,
що один з мотивів російської агресії проти України
в 2014 році полягав в тому, щоб не допустити
реалізації в Україні масштабних енергетичних проєктів.
Використавши західне паливо на радянських реакторах,
Україна стала прикладом для інших країн центральної
та східної Європи. На європейських реакторах
радянського дизайну відтепер є можливість швидко
відмовитися від російського палива.
Водночас Угорщина, Франція та Болгарія,
за інформацією ЗМІ, блокують санкції проти "Росатома"
саме через свою залежність від ядерного палива з Росії.
Західний світ досі купує російський збагачений уран.
З 2018 року ціни на уран зросли більш як удвічі.
Минулого року лише США заплатили "Росатому"
1 мільярд доларів.
Незважаючи на зростання цін, Росія залишається
найдешевшою альтернативою на світовому ринку.
Отримувати уран із Казахстану чи Росії дешевше.
Під час адміністрації Трампа обговорювалося питання
щодо обмеження імпорту урану.
Усі ці дискусії ні до чого не привели, бо галузь і так
перебувала у стресовому стані.
Оскільки у нас відносно низькі ціни на газ, що,
у свою чергу, призводить до низьких цін на
електроенергію, промислові підприємства сказали:
"Якщо ми не отримаємо цей дешевий уран,
ми не зможемо конкурувати і закриємося".
Дедалі більше країн у світі замислюються над
будівництвом атомних електростанцій.
Технології у цій сфері - ще один пункт російського експорту.
З 1999 року Росія продала за кордон більше технологій
для атомної енергетики, ніж США, Франція, Китай,
Південна Корея та Японія разом узяті.
З грудня 2019 року у світі розпочалося будівництво
28 атомних електростанцій,
17 з яких перебувають у Китаї.
Решту 11 "Росатом" будує в інших країнах.
Але й до 2019 року "Росатом" активно будував АЕС у Китаї,
Індії та Туреччині, а також у Єгипті, Бангладеш,
Ірані, і навіть Словаччині.
Нині Угорщина продовжує будівництво
нових енергоблоків спільно з "Росатомом".
Аби покласти край ядерній залежності від Росії
насамперед необхідна політична воля.
Але навіть за такої умови знадобляться роки
технологічних розробок та експериментів.